- [Gary] It's not
getting nice around here.
First, I went off on
the fucking bullshit ass,
loser ass, no chance ever
winning troll that was in here
and now DRock throwing
down on The Portuguese Wonder.
Chicks trying to get married.
Shit's going down
here on the delayed flight.
("Monday To Monday"
by Saba)
I've been telling you.
("Time To Fly" by Brainpower)
Talent is not
predicated on your age,
especially when the game
is conducive to
the youth, right?
Like my 30 years of basketball
experience is not helping me
against the top recruit
that's going to Duke this year.
And, (Jeff inaudible)
well, I don't know about that.
We haven't had our one-on-one.
We just haven't. I mean, listen.
- Bro, you can
actually post this.
He won't score.
He will not score.
- DRock, I will give him
the company if I don't score.
Give it to him.
Documented. Signed.
Put my fucking signature on it.
- There's no chance
you're gonna score.
There's no chance.
You might not even hit
the backboard with a shot.
- There's no chance
one-on-one that I don't score.
And to be very honest with you,
if you keep fucking talking
I'm just gonna beat you
outright. (Jeff laughs)
I don't know what else to say.
- Yo, DRock he's not
watching enough videos of
his actual game is the problem.
- I know my game.
Limited but I'll
tell you one thing,
I think I'm gonna win.
I don't know what to tell
you. (Gary and Jeff laugh)
Hey.
- [Woman] Hey, how are you?
- [Gary] How are you? Gary.
Such a pleasure.
Hey.
We know that every fucking
22-year-old in America grew up
editing film for the last 10
years and have real skills.
We're sorry that that happened.
We're sorry you don't have
to go to film school anymore
and just start learning.
And then, of course, by the time
you're 36 we apologize that
technology came
along and talent.
It's like you want,
I made the analogy today,
you want a 41-year-old
basketball player like me
because I've been
playing for 31 years or
do you want the
kid's that going to Duke?
Talent is a variable.
I know he's 17, he's
been playing for less time.
But that's what's
happening and so,
so back to where I was going.
I've already forgot.
I want to send one or two
of our film guys and gals
to these places...
Just leaving Chicago,
my PepsiCo client.
Great day, we had a lot of fun.
Intense meetings,
important meetings with some
agency partners and
with current clients.
Now, heading to L.A.
Good day, very focused so far.
Early morning, what's going on?
Snapchat just had an update.
Gonna look into that right now.
Gonna call the Resy
CTO, catch up with him.
That's it.
There's a huge
baseball bat right there.
No, no what are
you talking about?
- [DRock] Oh my God.
- [Gary] Thank you. It's a
good way to end that little...
Hit me with a comment if
you want in 6 to
9 P.M. secret event.
15 or more? 20?
What are you thinking?
- [Tyler] 15 to 20.
- [Gary] 15 to 20 of you are
going to come to a secret event
with me in the
Hollywood area in L.A.
I prepped this
video the other day.
Couple videos down
if you want to see it.
I'm wearing like a pink shirt.
Leave a comment
right now if you want in.
And I'll let one or two
plus-ones so if you want to tag
the other person
you want to come with,
that's a little secret thing.
Shhh.
But we're gonna DM you.
("My Soul" by Reap Youngin)
Something big. Super Bowl big.
It'd be really
fun if this happens.
Small percentage
chance but if it happens,
I'm gonna recall this moment.
And you'll be like
oh shit that was it.
That's when it happened.
What an amazing,
it's amazing to be
working with
progressive clients.
Hey guys, it's Gary.
I'm sitting here at the airport
going through my Instagram DM
'cause that's
where it goes down.
No, I can not be your mentor.
You guys can hear me, right?
No, I think it's good.
No one knows the CTA.
Okay, good.
Can you hear me right now?
Instagram, can you
hear me right now?
Los Angeles I will see you.
I will see you tomorrow as soon
as I can get in
this fucking plane.
I will see you
and I will bring it.
Secret thing, 25 people.
Trying to get a
couple more slots right now.
We're working on it.
Some of you are
probably getting hit up by
Sean Mack or Alex De Simone.
Fat Gary was fun.
- [DRock] Fat Gary?
- 2009, 2015.
There's a couple
real bad shots out there.
We need to dig those up and
really do a collage of Fat Gary.
We may need to make
a Fat Gary t-shirt.
You like that?
You like Fat Gary t-shirt?
- I would get it.
Could even wear it.
- Oh man.
Put in the work.
- Fat Gary, put in the work.
- Heart, good to see you.
Love it, love it, love it.
Alright, let's do
a ridiculous contest.
You know what
I liked the other day.
When I made everybody take a
screenshot of the livestream,
post it, whoops.
Post it, crap, did I end it? No.
Post it on their Instagram and
tag me but I should give away
something good like
what about an hour shadowing
DRock and me like in New York.
- [Amos] I was actually just on
the live stream and I actually
see you sitting here.
- How are you?
- It's nice to meet you. Amos.
- Amos, real
nice to meet you, man.
- I watch all your videos.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- Inspiration for sure, man.
- 'Preciate it.
- [Gary] Take care.
Wow, 3,000 on the
live stream. It's nice.
Okay, here's
what we're gonna do.
I'm gonna give you guys the
opportunity to hang out with me
and DRock for two hours.
Not one, they can shadow you.
I'll find like
five minutes here,
two minutes there, selfie,
answer a quick questions,
but I'm gonna live my normal
life but you come to New York,
hang out at VaynerMedia offices
for two hours and so that's what
you can do and so what you
have to do is you have to screen
shoot this, you have to screen
shoot this and you have to post
it on your Instagram right now.
And you need to tag me, 'cause
that's how I'm gonna find you.
I'm gonna use the
hashtag functionality.
So tag me in the photo, tag me
in the photo or use my handle in
your copy and say,
"GaryVee, give me
the two hours."
And you need to fly into
New York on your own dime or
drive or take the Path
if you live in east coast
or whatever but it
expires at the end of the year
so if you live somewhere and
you're gonna visit New York in
the summer, we can do it then.
That's what we're doing.
Let's do it right now.
Take a screen shot
right now off this.
Let me take some
nice glam shots so
I can look good
on your Instagram.
Oh actually, you know what?
No, if I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna clog up your feed you need
to tell people
why you follow me.
'Cause I'm attractive,
because I'm attractive,
'cause I'm
friends with Kevin Rose.
'Cause I'm attractive.
Or maybe it's inspire or I bring
value so not only you have to
say give me it you have to say
why you follow me and tell them
to follow me 'cause that's
what I'm getting and what you're
getting is two
hours with us in NYC.
How long do I create
content to ask for a favor?
Drunken, it all
depends on how good it is.
You could put one piece of
content that's so good that
everybody wants to give you
favors right away or it might
take you eight years
'cause the collective.
It's really just
a value exchange
that people don't understand.
This is all a value exchange.
So it's not about how
much content or how many days,
it's the quality.
It's like how much
value did you bring?
You put out one video
that changes everybody's life.
It could've
taken one day. Right?
So, that's what's up.
Canada, good to see you.
Kyle, what drives me is legacy.
I have this innate feeling
in my body that I'm special,
that I'm all-time and that I was
gifted with unbelievable talent,
enormous self-confidence
and humility which means
I'm balanced and I'm focused
and I can do shit and
so I feel almost a guilt of the
emotional intelligence that
I was gifted and so,
thus, the legacy and guilt and
ambition drive
the fuck out of me.
I don't care about money.
Money's already come,
money will continue to come.
People don't understand,
when you level up into passion,
ambition, legacy, passion,
legacy, ambition
then when you go with
those kind of tactics you start,
the money always comes.
Especially, if you got talent.
DRock is here.
Tyler is here.
Jay, Jay Deep, I'd love for
anybody to try to expose
me as a fraud, mother fucker.
Come see me, Jay Deep.
You're real fucking
tough with no icon.
Come see me, brother.
Come fucking see me.
Expose me for what?
I ain't asking for shit.
Why don't you come see me?
Bring your tax
fucking receipts, too.
Show me what you got, Jay.
Show me what you got, Jay Deep,
and you got what you want troll.
I gave you some love.
Enjoy it, drink it,
mother fucker.
Enjoy it. (laughs)
I love it.
I am savage, Nick.
People don't know,
I'm nice as fuck.
Tyler, what percent, what up?
You want me to
come over? Alright.
People at the store
want me to come over.
Trying to be on the live stream?
Get over here.
- You on live?
- [Gary] How you doing?
I'm live. What's your name?
- My name is Kellie.
- [Gary] Hi Kellie.
- Holla. Hey y'all.
- Tell them what's up.
- What's this, Instagram?
- Mhmmm.
Getting your hair right.
- What a minute.
- Tell them what's up.
- Follow my
Instagram Kellie_Badd.
- B-A-D-D, double D?
- Yeah.
- Double D, yeah, go ahead.
I don't really know
like what do you do.
- I'm just a businessman.
- This man told me you
were gonna own the Jets soon.
- That man was right.
- Really?
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Are you married?
- I'm married.
- Oh.
- Why? You
wanted to make a play?
- Yeah.
- I like your style.
(group laughter)
Good luck.
- Wait, can we take a picture?
- [Gary] He knows how to do it.
He's the best.
- [Kellie] Are you with him?
- [Gary] He sure is.
That's DRock.
- [DRock] Awesome.
- Good.
The MBeats, mother of five,
first of all, you're incredible.
Second of all, you got to start
a business that's practical
'cause raising five kids
is a triple full-time job.
I would say late nights,
try to build your brand.
Try to sell stuff.
The two things that I think
is most practical is either
building your personal brand on
social media or selling stuff on
Let Go, you know, Etsy, eBay,
those are the two
most practical things
that a mom of five could
actually pull off 'cause those are
things that you can
actually do damage at
8, 9, 10, 11, 12 P.M. You know?
8, 9, 10, 11 P.M.,
12 A.M., 1, 2, you know?
I love that DailyVee 101 is
incredible 'cause every time
I see DRock, he's all sad.
(Tyler laughs)
That dude came from Portugal and
fucking put together the
bomb piece of content.
- [DRock] Not sad.
Not sad.
- (laughs) I know,
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
Big ups, Brazil.
Oh Andy said, he's
in the chat, he's like,
"Sorry, DRock."
(DRock laughs)
I think you guys
have a real rivalry.
The Portuguese
Wonder is your rival.
He hasn't filmed anything.
Nice, DRock.
Oh, DRock's throwing down, Andy.
And it's not
getting nice around here.
First, I went off on
the fucking bullshit ass,
loser ass, no chance ever
winning troll that was in here
and now DRock throwing
down on The Portuguese Wonder.
Chicks trying to get married.
Shit's going down
here on the delayed flight.
Los Angeles, excited
for the 25 people that are
gonna win the contest tomorrow.
Secret event that
you're gonna be a part of.
Looking forward to it.
He gave you a touché. He
has respect for you filming.
The web show.
The Webby Show.
I know you love it, DRock.
Stop, everybody knows
you're a bad guy, DRock.
You play a good guy on camera
but we know he's a bad guy, Ty.
He's the worst guy we know.
What I'm doing is I'm gonna go
sign off right now and go into
the last post I posted
for the L.A. secret event
and I'm gonna go pick
six random winners right now.
So if you haven't
done that yet, go do that.
("My Soul" by Reap Youngin)